today's video is kindly sponsored by war
robots
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
the modern world is a remarkable place
we live in an age where most of us carry
around a device so advanced
its basic functions would have looked
like sorcery to our great great
grandparents
how may i serve you where computers
capable of exploiting the weirdness of
quantum physics
are trivializing feats of computation
that would the world's fastest
supercomputers
and where mcdonald's do home delivery
and yet despite these truly stunning
advances and bewilderingly complicated
technology
that underpins them the most remarkable
complex piece of state of the art tech
ever created
at least as far as we know has remained
pretty much the same for the last couple
of hundred
thousand years the human brain
[Music]
of all the assorted bits of meat that
come together to form you
your brain is arguably the most
important
when you look in the mirror you see well
you
and i'm not trying to freak you out here
but in a way
what you're actually looking at is a
human brain
attached to a life support machine and a
bunch of pretty cool accessories
okay so it's a little bit more
complicated than that but the bottom
line
is this your brain is inseparable
from you and without it
you not only wouldn't be the person you
are today
you wouldn't be a person at all
or would you because whilst
pretty much everything neuroscience
tells us about the human brain
confirms it is very much non-negotiable
for anyone who fancies being a fully
functional human
it just so happens that one man appears
to demonstrate that
grey mata doesn't well
matter this individual a 44 year old
frenchman
visited his local doctor complaining of
weakness in his legs
but on examining his patient the doctor
couldn't find any obvious
physical issues and so he decided a
brain scan was in order
when the results came back they were
both shocking
and extremely surprising because
the scan did indeed suggest a possible
reason for the man's malfunctioning legs
he didn't seem to have a brain
or at least not the kind of brain anyone
had ever seen before
it was absolutely tiny just
10 of the normal size if your average
human brain is a big strong
workhorse this man had somehow
been saddled with a shetland pony
and you can saddle yourself into the
pilot seat
of an epic war robot war robots is a
worldwide
real-time player vs player battle game
in which you aim to fill your hangar
with a collection of over 90 unique
robots
in order to dominate in legendary
battles against other mechanical giants
every robot possesses its own special
ability
such as flying or dash my personal
favorite is rhino who has the assault
ability
allowing him to gain extra protection
from his built-in shields
i really love the amazing graphics and
war robots and the gameplay is so much
fun
and the matchmaking facility is just
fantastic with over 190 million players
worldwide
there's always someone to play with i
never have to wait long to jump into a
match
and start destroying enemy robots you
can download and play war robots
on your mobile phone or on your pc using
my link in the description below
or just scan my qr code to receive a
starter pack
which includes a robot with a weapon and
a unique skin
100 gold and 50 000 silver
check it out
okay so first things first where had the
man's brain
gone let's be clear it hadn't fallen out
that probably isn't a thing no
sections of this man's brain the lateral
ventricles
had slowly filled up with cerebrospinal
fluid
over the course of 30 years gradually
compressing the rest of his brain
to a tiny fraction of the normal size
all of this came as a result of a
condition known as hydrocephalus
which demand had first been diagnosed
with as a six-month-year-old baby
at the time he was treated through the
insertion of a shunt
to drain the brain of fluid this
technique worked
and the shunt was removed when he was 14
which turned out not to have been the
best decision
as his skull had been gradually filling
right back up again with fluid
ever since what's truly remarkable about
this story
is that the man with the pygmy brain
appeared to have been living a
completely normal life
in spite of his condition in fact
neither he
nor anyone who knew him had any idea
there was anything wrong with him
he had a good job working as a civil
servant
and he was married with two kids there
was nothing about his life that
suggested he was suffering from
catastrophic brain damage
it turned out he did have an iq on the
low side
at 75 very likely caused by the
condition
but that's just about within the normal
range
so how on earth is this even possible
we're used to thinking of the human
brain as a powerful but
somewhat delicate piece of machinery i
mean there's a reason you wear a helmet
when you ride a bike
breaking an arm or a leg is usually
little more than
an extremely painful inconvenience
breaking your head on the other hand is
an instant
game over screen no extra life
no continues and it isn't just
unfortunate accidents that have taught
us to be careful with our noggins
in response to the rising number of
people residing in mental institutions
a man named antonio igaz moniz
who for reasons i don't quite understand
looks like he should be on display at
madam two swords
anyway he pioneered a new kind of brain
surgery to help people suffering from a
variety of mental illnesses
the technique was so successful it
earned monies the 1951
nobel prize for medicine you might have
heard of it actually
the lobotomy yeah
as you're probably already aware a
lobotomy is an incredibly controversial
surgery
that essentially involves the severing
of nerves linking various sections of
the brain
now it has to be said a good lobotomy if
that's ever a thing
could be surprisingly successful at
eliminating the symptoms of mental
illness
with the minor downside that common side
effects included
confusion incontinence mental detachment
and total personality deletion
and all of that from just snipping a few
nerve fibers here and there
which brings me back to my previous
question if
comparatively minor damage to the brain
is associated with such
debilitating symptoms how is it possible
that a man whose brain was slowly
squeezed to a tiny fraction of the
proper size
was even still breathing let alone
living a normal life without the
slightest idea
that anything was wrong with him well
despite those pretty
shocking brain scans the important thing
to realize here is that the frenchman's
miniature brain still had all the
important bits intact
the immense pressure inside the cranium
hadn't destroyed his brain
or at least not much of it only squished
it
it was a bonsai brain if you like
small but perfectly formed if you were
to lop the top of someone's skull off
hannibal lecter style and violently
compress
their brain to ten percent of its
original size
you would no doubt kill them instantly
and make
quite a mess in the process but in the
case of our unlucky frenchman
the miniaturization process happened
over a period of decades
giving his brain time to adapt to its
new
cozier accommodation which just goes to
show how adaptable the human body really
is
even the brain early reports on this
case suggested not that the man's brain
had been squashed
but that ninety percent of his brain had
been destroyed somehow
and if that had have been true we would
have had to completely revaluate
everything we thought we knew about the
brain after all it simply is impossible
for anyone to survive with large chunks
of the brain missing
or is it well as it happens our bonsai
brain
frenchman isn't the only person in
history to have pulled off the
rather neat trick of living a fairly
normal existence
despite unimaginable damage to their
brain
in 2014 neuroscientists reported on a
case in which a 24 year old
chinese woman was found to be missing a
part of the brain
called the cerebellum now when it comes
to the brain
pretty much everything's important but
the cerebellum
is particularly so it's estimated to
contain
half the neurons in the entire brain and
it plays a key role in coordination
balance language emotion memory
and attention most doctors will tell you
that without a cerebellum
you don't really have a brain at all and
yet
somehow this woman had managed without
hers
for 24 years and much like our mini
brain
french bloke she only discovered her
predicament
when she went to hospital complaining
about seemingly unrelated symptoms
of nausea and dizziness doctors
scanned her brain and found simply a big
black space where the cerebellum should
have been
on further investigation it did turn out
there were a few clues not everything
was quite right
the woman hadn't learned to walk until
she was seven
and even then she struggled a little
with movement
she also found speech difficult and
wasn't able to make herself
understood until the age of six but
even so doctors were amazed she was even
alive
only eight other people are known to
have survived for
any length of time without a cerebellum
usually the lack of one causes death at
an early age
and is only discovered during an autopsy
likewise adults who suffer severe damage
to the cerebellum
through a head injury for example are
typically
unable to walk or even stand
how exactly someone can live a
relatively normal life with a big
chunk of their brain missing is still
something of a mystery to medicine
but it seems that other parts of the
brain are somehow
able to compensate for the bits that are
missing
we see this kind of thing happen in the
brains of blind people
where the visual cortex is repurposed
for auditory tasks
another woman american michelle mack was
only born with half a brain
like the chinese woman with no
cerebellum it had always been obvious
things weren't quite right
and she did have some learning
difficulties but
no one knew why doctors believe she had
a stroke while still in the womb
and this meant the left half of her
brain just didn't grow
but the right side did it grew normally
and was able to compensate to a
surprisingly large extent
for the half that should have been there
and wasn't
accidental brain loss isn't the only
thing that our brains can come back from
some people have actually had half of
their brain deliberately removed
usually as a treatment for severe
epilepsy or another neurological
disorder
one such person is christina sandhouse
in 1996 she had the entire right
hemisphere of her brain
removed she was just eight years old at
the time
and had been diagnosed with rasmussen's
encephalitis
a rare brain disease that causes
constant seizures
christina would have up to 150 seizures
per day
making her life near enough unlivable
her doctors told the parents she would
die
if they didn't do something drastic and
something drastic is exactly what they
did
the operation took 14 hours and half her
brain
and it saved christina's life she grew
up healthy
earned two degrees and qualified as a
speech pathologist
there are some serious downsides to the
procedure as you might expect
patients lose the use of their hand on
the opposite side of the body
to the removed brain hemisphere as well
as vision on that side
but particularly if the surgery is
carried out at a young age
many complex cognitive functions things
like memory
and personality develop completely
normally
the truth is we still don't know exactly
how our brains are able to overcome
things like
being squashed to a fraction of their
original size or
chopped in half neuroplasticity
certainly plays an important part that's
the ability for our brains to
physically change in response to our
environment
as does the fact that our brains are
master multitaskers
remember how i mentioned the visual
cortex is repurposed in the brains of
blind people
to process auditory information well it
turns out that
some level of auditory information
processing
goes on in the visual cortex of people
who can see just
fine too which sounds surprising
until you remember that the visual
cortex is just a name we humans happen
to give to that part of the brain
based on our still fairly limited
knowledge
of what goes on in there in recent
decades scientists have spent a lot of
time trying to figure out which bits of
the brain do what
but whilst we're able to associate
certain activities with specific regions
of the brain it's becoming increasingly
clear
that things are much much more
complicated than that
and that multiple regions of the brain
are typically involved with any one
function
which helps explain how when one area of
the brain is damaged
it's easier for others to pick up the
slack so
there you have it owning a fully
functional brain may not be quite so
important as you force it was
still probably best to keep wearing that
helmet when you ride your bike
just in case thanks for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks